what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um
today i have a morning coffee thought
um
and today's morning coffee thought is
talking about kevin
samuels
um as you guys may or may not know he
passed away i think last night or maybe
the day before
i first heard i saw in the comment
section on my stream that he died but i
wasn't sure if it was true so i was kind
of just waiting for the news to come out
um but a couple like sources close to
kevin confirmed that he did in fact pass
away
um
so i'm gonna try to like
do him justice
but
i wanted to like talk about my
experience with him
and how he impacted my life so
i first came into kevin samuel's content
in
the spring of like last year i you
probably could look on my channel and
find the first video where it's like
whitest girl on earth reacts to kevin
samuels for the first time or something
like that
and to be honest i really wasn't like a
big fan of his um i i really didn't like
his content at first
um until i kept listening and i kept
watching because you know people that
reaction blew up so i just kept reacting
to his content
so so
um
i actually grew
to not only like love kevin samuels but
like really appreciate like what he's
doing
um and for me as a girl i felt like
listening to his content like after you
know i got over the you know initial
hurdle i felt like he was giving girls
the cheat code to how to like deal with
guys um
so
i don't know i it was i just couldn't
stop watching this stuff like i've
listened to every broadcast
um so until
um the first time i met kevin which was
on his show
so i called into his show um
about a year ago now like last
summer
and what a lot of people don't know is
that after the summer i actually or
after that show i got into a call with
him
and at this point in my life i was going
through like a lot of
how did i put it i was going through a
lot of like self-esteem issues to be
honest like i just had like really low
confidence um i was in a relationship
that was like pretty toxic
um
i was kind of heavy like i was the
heaviest i've been in a minute
um
i
i don't know i just like
i just like really mentally was in a bad
place and so i i got on this call with
him
and
um
i told him my situation and he actually
told me to leave it
he told me to leave that relationship
he told me that i had that i was a wife
and
to
you need to find a husband not a
boyfriend
um he told me
that
i
had a multi-million dollar business on
my hands for youtube he just gave me a
lot of like
confidence
it was it sounds silly right random man
on youtube gives you
gives
girl con but but it really did and it
really like pushed me
to keep like working towards what i was
doing
um
the last time i talked to kevin so that
was the first time the last time i
talked to kevin
um i was asking him for youtube advice
and this man oh my god he completely
roasted what i was doing
like he told me
and you can see this he told me like
it's not about the channel is not about
you you can't just post what you want
you need to like
like be special he was roasting me i'm
not even gonna lie to you and honestly
like after that call i took his advice
and three months later my channel
doubled in growth
so
a lot of people don't know that i
actually like talk to them a couple
times behind the scenes and
i
i think it's crazy how
you know
this man can be at the peak of his
career peak of his life really and just
after one second he's gone
um so he
helped me
and he helped me in a lot of ways if i
didn't talk to him i might still be in
that like super toxic relationship
um
and
i don't know just
watching like the [ __ ] that he's
accomplished this year has been so cool
like honestly i i would say he's the
king of the man of sphere he set the
trends
if kevin samuels was talking about it
everyone was talking about it
um so
um i'm glad that
he
at least got like you know at least his
message got out there before he passed
but it really shows you that
you
you just never know when someone's gonna
go so
i don't know i just
i just wanted to pay my respect and like
tribute to him i think he is such a
great man um
i actually was working to build this
show my whole goal i actually when i
talked to him
and it was like december was the last
time i talked to him and again i've only
talked to him maybe like four or five
times in my whole life but the last time
i talked to him he
said he was coming to london in the
spring and my whole goal with my show
was to like get it big enough so he
would come on
um
like that was that was a really big like
goal for me
so
i didn't know like when he was coming
but
i i don't know i was trying to
it's just i don't know it's just crazy
that he's gone because
he literally changed the culture
so
um any and any girl
that the these nasty ass comments that
have been coming up that are wishing
death upon this man and saying
like i'm not even gonna repeat them but
these terrible ass comments that are
coming out that [ __ ] is not cool
um and honestly as women it reflects on
all of us poorly when we have girls that
are coming out and like preying upon
this man's death that's crazy that's
insane
so
um yeah i just i i wouldn't have had
built this platform without him i would
never have gotten into red pill
um i started into the manosphere by
reacting to his content i never would
have found any of this if it wasn't for
him so
um
yeah and the man of spheres changed my
life like
i went from doing reactions to running a
whole live youtube show and none of that
would have happened without kevin
samuels so
um
yeah
rest in peace because
like that's
yeah this is
just not nuts
so um i'm i don't know i'm sending
prayers to his family and his supporters
and
i hope
we can all you know
use his message to like better our lives
and still better
the movement of the man of sphere and
fight for men's rights and advocate for
men because that's like that's that's
what he would have wanted so
thanks for watching guys um i hope i
hope that did him justice i don't know
but
thanks for watching love you guys bye